on Tuesday January 16 1996 I walked into
the office of the president as head of
state of the Republic of Sierra Leone I
had not been elected four years earlier
I was one of thirty heavily armed
military officers or in our 20s who had
driven from the war front into the
capital city freedom we had only one
objective to overthrow a corrupt
repressive and single party dictatorship
that had kept itself in power for over
25 years but in the end it wasn't a
violent coup after all fired a few shots
and seized the radio station hundreds of
thousands of citizens jumped onto the
street to welcome us as liberators if
you are thinking this seems like a movie
script I'm with you I was part of the
ruling military government and I served
in several rules our goal was always to
return the country to democratic
civilian rule but after four years those
multi-party democratic elections are
still not happened citizens we are
beginning to lose faith in our promise
you know what I like to keep my promises
some of my comrades and I staged another
military coup at this time against our
own head of state and commander again it
was a bloodless coup that is how I
became the new military head of state in
January 16 1996
I was the only 31 years would of course
PowerSuite I felt invulnerable I had
thousands of heavily armed men and
aircraft at my command I was heavily
protected and I lived in luxury but my
obligations to my nation we are always
superior millions of fellow citizens we
are either displaced or fleeing the
violence and pillage of war
so I engage in a theory of diplomatic
activities right across the sub-region
and convinced the reclusive rebel leader
to initiate peace talks for the very
first time I also called a national
consortium conference of civil society
organizations and stakeholders to advise
on the best way forward in both cases I
shared with them what I believed in them
in them and now the Syrian is bigger
than all of us and that Syrian must be a
secure peaceful and just society where
every person can thrive and contribute
to national development and so I
initiated pistol with the rebels I
organized the first multi-party
democratic election in nearly 30 years
I handed over power to the newly elected
president I retired from the Army and I
left my country for the United States of
America to study or in three months in
many a long walk
I wondered how we could get it again how
would you get it right again as a nation
more than 20 years later in every 2018
with a few more wrinkles and hey here I
was again head of state but guess what
this time I have been democratically
elected at the police station last year
my three-year-old daughter Amina was in
Miami she insisted on holding onto my
ballot paper with me she was intent and
focused at that moment with my ballot
paper in both our hands I fully
understood the one priority for me if I
was elected president of the Republic
Australia that is how could I make the
lives of Amina and millions of other
young girls and boys better in our
country I believe that leadership is
about creating possibilities that
everyone especially the young people can
believe in own work to actualize and
which they can actively fight to protect
the pathway to power and leadership can
be littered with impediments but more
often with funny questions that may
seemingly defy answers how does one take
on the unique challenges of a country
like Sue Ellen we had mined mineral
resources for over 100 years but we
still are poor we had collected foreign
aid for 58 years
but we asleep or the secrets to economic
development is in nature's best resource
skilled healthy and productive human
beings the secret to changing our
country lay in enhancing and supporting
the limitless potential of the next
generation and challenging them to
change our country human capital
development was the key to national
development in Syria as a candidate I
met with and listened to many young men
and women right across the country and
in the Diaspora that we are feeling
disconnected from political leadership
and cared little about the future of our
country how could we engage them and
make them believe that the answers to
transforming our nation was right in
their hands
immediately after becoming president I
appointed some of coeruleus brightest
young people as leaders with
responsibility to realize our shared
vision of transforming Syrian I am
grateful many of them said yes let me
give you a few examples corruption had
been endemic in governance institutions
and in public life in Syria on the
mining public trust and the country's
international reputation I appointed a
young authority as commissioner for the
anti-corruption Commission in less than
a year he had a hundred percent
conviction rate and recovered over 1.5
million dollars of stolen money that is
seed money for building the country's
first ever national medica that gnostics
center Israeli on
the Bellini incorporation challenge
recently gave us a green scorecard for
the control of corruption indicator a
multilateral development partners that
had less really on are now beginning to
return we are determined to break a
culture of corruption and the culture of
impunity that is associated with
corruption before I became president I
had I met a skinny dreadlock MIT Havana
inventor in London over coffee I
challenged him to think and plan along
with me how innovation could help to
drive national development in the areas
of governance revenue mobilisation
healthcare education delivering public
services and supporting private sector
growth how cost really impart issah
pates in the digital economy and become
an innovation hub guess what
he left his cozy job at IBM and he now
lives a team of young men and women
within the newly established Directorate
of science technology and innovation in
my own office
that young man is right in here I
challenge another youngster a lenient
woman to set up and leave the new
Ministry of planning and economic
development
she consulted Wiley with with shreya
linens and produced in record time the
medium-term national development plan
tight food education for development we
now have our national development needs
in easily understandable clusters and we
can now plan our budget align
development partner contributions and
measure our own progress but the story
of my government's flagship program is
even more daring if I can call it that
today three out of five adults in
Australian cannot read or write
thousands of children we are not able to
go to school or had dropped out of
school because their parents will not
just afford the $20.00 school fees per
year we many girls who constitute 51% of
our population we are not given equal
opportunity to be educated so the
audience answer is to put in place free
quality education for every civilian and
child regardless of gender ability or
ethnicity
great idea you've clapped for right but
the only problem is we had no money to
start the program absolutely nothing
development partners wanted to see data
before associating with my vision of
course political opponents and laughed
at me but I campaigned that a nation
that invest in human capital development
through free quality education
affordable and high quality health care
services and food security we accelerate
its national development program I
argued that foster alien to produce
highly-skilled
innovative and productive workforce fit
for the 21st century global economy we
needed to invest heavily in human
capital development in the radio but we
had no money because the previous
government had virtually emptied the
coffers we clamped down on corruption
closed up the loopholes for fraud and
waste and we watched the money build-up
we successfully launched free quality
education program in August last year
for year four months later today two
million children are going to school
21% of national budget supports free
quality education in close collaboration
and in partnership with development
partners we have now provided teaching
and learning materials safe spaces for
girls and started implementing school
feeding program across the entire
country we haven't paid back logs of
salaries for teachers any girl admitted
to university to study science
technology engineering mathematics and
other related disciplines receives full
scholarship in Sierra Leone today and
here is why this matters in a few years
we will have a healthier better educated
and highly skilled young population that
we lead and drive the country's national
development know be well equipped to
deploy science technology and innovation
they will attract investment in
diversified areas of our economy from
tourism to fisheries and from new
renewable energy to manufacturing that
is my biggest bet in my mind this is
what leadership is all about a mission
to listen with empathy to the creators
of ideas the hopes and aspirations of a
younger generation who are just looking
for a chance to be better and to make
our country better it is about letting
them know that their dreams matter it is
about standing with them and asking why
not when they ask seemingly impossible
questions it is about exploring making
and owning a shared vision the most
audacious and nation changing events or
policies or even personal choices happen
when we ask why not
they make bold choices and ensure those
booth
choices happen I wake up every day
believing that our country should no
longer be defined by the stigma of the
past the future of us hope and
opportunity for all it matters to me
that young men and women right across
the country can imagine for themselves
that they too can be an eye patch of the
story of our nation I want to challenge
them to build a nation we have three
year old olds like my daughter year Amy
can grow up in good governance quality
education health care and good
infrastructure I want our children to
become young men and women who can
continue nourishing the trees that we
grow from the seeds that we are planting
today now can someone tell me why we
should not dare imagine that future in
Sierra Leone thank you
[Applause]